all right
hello everybody
hope everybody is having a fruitful lent
um
at least for me it's been really hard
for some reason lent has just been
really intense and i think it's uh
i think it's uh it has to do with just
everything that's going on it's just
hard to man just hard to
it's just hard to focus properly so um
yeah
good to see brad in the chat
and uh this time i realized last time
that i
had posted because the people that give
ten dollars or more can ask questions in
advance and then i just send that thing
uh message out to people and then i i
just forgot to send to all the other
subscribers and patrons
i forgot to send the message and so i
was like why are there so few people in
the uh
in the chat and then that's probably why
so hopefully we'll have more people and
also people who are
members of this of the facebook group
can also have access so you know and
everybody else will you know watch later
hopefully we can get involved in the
chat as well
um and so as you know you know people
send in their questions and uh we kind
of whittle them down to about 50
questions and so this time from 80 we
went down to a little bit less than 50
and so don't be
don't be surprised if your question
doesn't uh appear usually if it doesn't
appear it's because i've often been
asked that question before um or it's
convoluted or uh yeah so all right let's
do this
and so uh i'm going to start with a
question
from reno gagne
those who don't know reno you probably
don't know him but he he's really one of
the people that helped me to set up like
the nfts for god's dog he's been really
involved in crypto and helping me
understand crypto and so he asked a
question
i have a burning question about
technology am i using technology or is
technology using me
at the rate of change
as the rate of change is accelerating
technologies capacities
are growing exponentially i wonder if
there is a time where christians should
stead up step off this train i'm feeling
the effects of my participation with
technology and how it is shaping my
heart and mind as we move towards
technocracy technopoly
when do we say
no more and so
i obviously have been thinking about
that quite a bit myself and so i think
that there will be a point where we're
going to have to step off i don't know
if
if it keeps going this way which it
probably will
i don't know if it's the same for
everybody i think it really you have to
be attentive to your own
passions and
let's say what's driving you like you
said
and so for sure your frame is right that
is this is the issue of
technology in general you could say it's
the issue of the garments of skin you
know right from the outset in the story
of genesis
where
you know the garments of skin are meant
to protect you are meant to increase
your power are meant to give you
possibilities in a world of chaos and of
death but it they also
have in them a kind of cycle of desire
that is difficult to avoid and the kind
of drunkenness of power that it brings
and so
and so i think that that's definitely
the case especially for like phones and
internet and all this stuff
yeah it's not easy so i do think that at
some point it might be necessary to step
off but i'm not sure when that is for
everybody it's not exactly the same some
people might never
step off but
for sure i thought about it you know
like kind of how when it would be
necessary for me to do that and uh
i haven't totally
come to the conclusion yet so
yeah
all right and so we're going to start
with people who support me through the
symbolic world website
so cormac jones asks hello jonathan what
do you know of the use
of the word symbol and its cognates in
the greek bible any key passages
thank you so much
so
i think that one of my favorite use of a
sim symbol cognate is actually i forget
what the reference is but it's the
moment when uh it's after the the birth
of christ
after the magi so i guess it would be in
the gospel of matthew i guess uh after
the the the magi
come to see christ
it it says that the that the mother of
god that mary
gathered these things
in her heart and the word uh
gather in her heart is a cognate to
symbol
symbolo or something and i always
thought that that was one of the best
image
images of symbolism that you could find
with this image of
the virgin that is the the feminine
aspect
that gathers these seeds that she
receives
that it's almost like an image of it's
like a lower image of something which
happened at the incarnation itself that
is she gathered in her center in her
heart
and by bringing all these disparate
elements and gathering in the center
that is really a good definition of what
symbolism is you know she's
she keeps them together and gathers them
in a way that makes them a whole you
know and remembers them because there's
a definitely a relationship between
symbolism and memory in general because
memory is the manner in which
disparate things are connected to
something that is far away from them so
it's like how do i
if i remember my mother it's because
she's she's not there she's far and so
there's a manner in which
to remember god is also to bring
together even in the word to remember to
bring back together to to take disparate
elements and bring them together towards
something so um so that's what i think
one of the best places that i find a
cognate for symbol in the bible
and so brad says uh compare the
etymology of symbolic and diabolic yeah
exactly having a few several people
bring that out which diabolos means to
separate and symbolic means to bring
together so we can kind of understand
what it is that the devil does the devil
you know a satanic
like a satanic move
is to
show how things are break apart and not
how they come together to tend to only
emphasize the manner in which things are
separate and not the manner in which
things are together so you can
understand that in
in even within
analytic thinking if you're not careful
you can fall into a kind of diabolical
uh a diabolical path where you're always
tending to break things apart to their
to their constitutive elements and you
become cynical about the manner in which
they join together in higher meaning so
all right so ramal asks hi jonathan what
is the symbolism of monkeys apes in the
medieval world view my guess is that it
does have a little relationship with
acenocephaly but it seems a little
limiting also what are the symbolic
aspects of the more modern trends of
human
evolution and so i think that it's
interesting there are some medieval
legends that are interesting about
monkeys and apes for example so
you can see there's a there's a legend
for example in this in
the nativity gospels that talks about
christ in egypt
who encounters uh
a slave and this slave is bothering it's
a really weird story so don't don't be
surprised so
this slave is bothering christ for some
reason when he's a baby and you know
because he's all powerful he changes her
into a monkey
and then the mother of god uh she
she she tells him that you can't do that
basically you shouldn't do that and so
he brings he turns it back into a human
but
there are legends like that for example
there are weird jewish legends from the
middle ages that talk about how the
descendants of cain
became apes
and there's also a whole idea of like
you said the notion of the cenocephaly
that there's a possibility that one of
the one of the encounters that brought
about the stories of the cenocephali was
people from the north you know europeans
or whatever that encountered apes and
were not able to discern
whether or not
what they were dealing with was human or
not and it just because they weren't
used to seeing apes and apes stand up
and they have features that are similar
to ours and so there's a sense in which
they kind of like are they are this kind
of weird in-between space between humans
and other animals and that they could be
perceived that way but what's
interesting mostly is to understand how
in the medieval mind they see it
ontologically they don't see it as the
evolutionists think of it in terms of
like a progress of mechanical uh
mechanical and physical um causality
they see it ontologically as you know
apes are
lower than humans and so the idea that
like as cane degrades and goes down into
the body and loses the higher aspect of
him then he would become
a monkey like he would become an ape and
that type of thinking is still there
today you know when someone
suggests that someone when in
evolutionary thinking there's a whole
mythology mythological thinking so for
example when a progressive talks about
how someone is
is you know uh like a caveman or someone
is retrograde you know he's from the
past what they're suggesting is that
that person is more like an ape than i
am that's what they're suggesting so
what what a medieval person might have
suggested ontologically in terms of
someone who is more animalistic would
have been more like an ape more like uh
like like a monkey the progressive does
it in time and tends to talk about the
you know the the the dumb you know the
dumb hick or whatever that's almost like
a caveman or almost like like an ape so
so you can see that a lot of these
things still
are still around like the same way of
thinking it's just framed a little
differently but it ends up being very uh
very similar
and so i actually talked about this in
the article that i wrote for the secrets
of god's dog for our for our uh comic
book i wrote about the relationship
between
this kind of progressive sin and even
there's a video about that i think it's
called how we dehumanize where you can
you can watch that video and get a sense
of of how different people dehumanize in
terms of uh seeing others as animals
so annie crawford says devolution yeah
exactly there's a sense there really is
a sense that that that's more the
medieval way of thinking
um
but it's interesting to understand so
like when when the evolutionist says
something like the origin of the humans
is apes
they're saying a lot about what their
worldview really is
because their worldview is based only in
in like physical phenomena and physical
changes then they tend to
they will tend to say something like the
origin of man is an eighth which is
crazy if you really think about it it's
like the origin
i mean and it's as stupid as saying
something like uh you know the origin of
of uh of michelangelo's david is a
quarry
it's like instead of looking at the
intelligent part of it they look at just
the the the physical characteristics and
they see that as the origin but that's
that's because they don't understand
right they don't understand how they
can't see how things come together into
purposes and things come together into
identities and those identities are
higher than
the the you know it's like uh
it's like when morons these morons you
hear sorry i'm being a little aggressive
here but when you hear these these
people say something like you know
you're 99.9
the same as a monkey and you're like
okay dude
what does that even mean that doesn't
mean anything you could say something
like i'm also 99 the same as anything
you want to depending on how you
calculated you could say i'm not
compared to uh you know compared to this
i'm 99 the same as a blade of grass like
these types of comparisons are so
silly and absurd it's like qualitative
difference is what is the real
difference not these quantitative
differences you know the difference
between an ape and a human if you can't
see the difference between an ape and a
human you
know you're in serious trouble my friend
because
the difference is very qualitative it's
like it's the difference between someone
who can
who can name the other and the other
that can't name back it's like that's
the difference between a human and an
ape uh it's like
i can tame an ape and an ape can't tame
me it's pretty as it's pretty simple
it's pretty simple
all right
i can put a i can put an ape and a zoo
and a zoo can put an a can't uh an ape
can't put a human in a zoo it just
that's
that's pretty much a good way to
understand the difference between uh a
man and a name anyway sorry i don't want
to go too hard on the poor
the poor evolutionists all right here we
go okay so douglas matthew says i've
been trying to understand the symbolism
of taking the mark on your right hand
versus your forehead could you go into
this a bit
a popular stance seems to be that it is
about those who take the mark do so in
both their actions yes and their mind
but it sounds to me like it is more
about how types of people the true
believers the people who simply go along
with it
in only an external way even if
unwilling are still guilty of receiving
the mark so i mean i think you're right
that the the emphasis on having a mark
on your forehead and on your hand has to
do with identity and action you know the
identity of your
you have to understand head
not just as mind but really as the place
of identity because right this is where
this this is where i encounter you like
if i think of someone i think of this
think of their face like head face
that's where identity is and so i think
that has to do with that it has to do
with identity with identification and
then action
and so the idea of a mark on your
forehead and on your hand actually comes
from scripture right it's the idea that
you should have the law on your forehead
and on your hand which is where the
whole jewish practice of having the
teflon you know wrapped around you see
these people with like the a little box
on their forehead the orthodox jews and
you see them with like things wrapped
around their their hands it has to do
it's a ritual version of the idea of
having the law
in your id in your identity and in your
action and i think that that's what it
means and i think that's what it also
means
in um that's what it also means in terms
of the idea of the the mark in
revelation it has to do with identity
with identification and action so you
can see it right that's why it says that
if you don't receive the mark then you
can't buy or sell like you can't you
can't act in the world
but that but it has to do with you being
accounted for in your identity as well
so that's the best way i think to
understand that
um
all right so gideon u says hello
jonathan what symbolism would you see in
the story of joseph being sold into
egypt
where ruben is one who tries to deliver
joseph from death and plans to save him
from the pit but judah is the one who
comes up with a plan to sell
joseph to the ishmaelites
yeah well there's definitely something
about that and there's definitely
something about
there's definitely something about how
that relates to christ as well because
ultimately
it's you could say that it's judah
judas
who also sells uh
christ
to the romans
in the microcosm of the story in terms
of
of um
the story of judas in the bible the the
character judas but then also
in general judah in in terms of the jews
of the period who give who gave christ
over to the romans to crucify him so
always to remember that
that uh right it's the romans that
physically crucified christ but they
were
you know you could say something like
judas sold
christ to the
to to the to the sanhedrin and then or
to the to the pharisees or whoever it
was the the people responsible and then
then they sold basically christ to over
to the egyptians over to the foreigners
and so that's the
that's the the the story
[Music]
so how's that related to the fact that
jesus is descended from judah and so but
there's a there's a there's a duality in
the story of
of of judah you know and there's also
the idea that the king or the lion of
judah right that the line of judah
is a particular thing you always
remember that a lion is also like an
impure animal and there's a relationship
between
the king
and
and this and the the
the character of judah is a shady
character in a lot of stuff if you know
the story of judah and also the
relationship the kind of illegitimate
types of relationships and there's also
in judah there's a breakdown of
of causality because he has a daughter
he has a child with his
with his own daughter-in-law and so
there's this there's this kind of
breakdown of causality and the the
messiah christ
gathers it all together
christ gathers
the best and the worst
of the old testament
in us in a way and that's why in in the
genealogy of
of the messiah that it's important to
mention the places where
he also comes from weird illegitimate
relationships you know for example
david and bathsheba who married the wife
of his
uh you know of of someone else's wife
and then you also have the story of of
ruth that is a strange woman and
you know you have all these
yeah all these stories so um
anyways
yeah the the christ is of is very very
mysterious guys there's a lot of there's
a lot of stuff in the store of jesus
that is
that is difficult to totally you know
like i said he crashes your categories
all right so
pkb5021 says what does it mean that the
mother of god has many identities idea
or lady of sorrows or lady of guadalupe
i know christ took on many identities as
well as a king teacher carpenter etc but
often you don't specify pray to jesus
the carpenter like you might to our lady
of sorrows uh
is this something to do with the
feminine i mean
i mean i would say it it's not it's not
exactly the same and
also there's a there's an idea in which
a person has different
manifestation and so a good way to maybe
understand that in terms of christ would
be that you don't have the same stance
if you look at an image of christ on the
cross as you have when you look at the
image of christ as the the
the pantocrator as the ruler of all you
don't have the same stance when you see
christ as a child in the arms of his
mother as you do when and this is all
christ but there but
you know christianity is is a place in
which unities and multiplicities coexist
and so the same with the the aspect of
the mother of god where the mother of
god has different aspects to her you
know the
her role as the one that gathers
you know and manifests and shows the way
to to christ then there are different
aspects of her as well like you said
there is her grieving for her son there
is her showing the way her opening the
way for christ to
his ministry uh for being the space in
which christ manifests himself so
there's all these aspects and different
aspects
in um
in orthodoxy often they'll even be like
different icons that manifest different
aspects of of the mother of god um you
know sometimes more affection sometimes
more of a showing
so i think that that's completely normal
it's not something that is that is weird
and the closer you get to something
which
holds everything together the more
aspects
will
can become explicit and so i mean take
an example let's say you have a
a saint that's
maybe not as important then it's not
like there'll be all these aspects of
that saint that we'll think about that
we'll meditate on that we'll remember
but when you
come to someone when you come to christ
who is the god incarnate then all of a
sudden his aspects become bright and we
can see them as manifesting in the
multiplicity the source of things so i
think it's the same
with the mother of god as the container
there are so many aspects to the notion
of that which contained the infinite in
her
that we sometimes have to meditate on
the different aspects or
invoke the different aspects
um
you know in order to kind of come closer
to the mystery of how it all comes
together
to me that's the best way of
understanding that
all right so david flores asks i asked
about the symbolism of hornets in a
previous q a and how god sent them for
the israelites all i could come up with
is
hornets are bees that do not produce
honey
their stings make blisters i feel like
it's connected to moses his hand
turning white somehow i'm at the limits
of my intuition have you had any time to
think about the symbolism i did it i'm
sorry but i think your intuition is
completely is right on i think that that
that definitely
that hornets don't have a useful they
don't they're not useful to
to humans like bees are and so bees are
like roses right they have a they have a
sting but they also have a sweetness or
have something sweet whereas the hornet
is only
is only let's say rigor right only the
the the
the sword only the
the harsh aspect of of like divine
revelation you could say so
yeah i think you've got it right i think
you're on the right thing where whether
that has to do with
moses's hand turning white
not sure
not sure
yeah i'm not sure i'd have to you you're
you're bringing about some interesting
images that i definitely have to think
about
and so patrick blocks because the
hornets maybe relate to thorns
definitely relate to thorns they're
definitely related to thorns like active
thorns you can say so you can imagine
like the judgment of god kind of coming
out as you know raging fire like
that kind of stuff you know
all right see this was patrick blonsky
said that so say strichel c c street
soul said hello jonathan what is the
symbolism of the hunter fisherman and
wild meat opposed to shepherds
agriculturalist livestock
and
crops
um
yeah
and so there's a there's definitely the
hunter fisherman
so there is an opposition between the
idea of the
let's say the shepherd and the
agriculturist in terms of civilization
the hunter fisherman obviously has
something to do with
more kind of active aggressive
male
energy i don't know how else to say it
right the idea of going out into the
world and
and hunting down you know finding
something aiming at it you know killing
it and then using it as uh potential so
you know that's why
you know if you think of
the one of the images of imperial or
tyrannical civilization in the bible
would even is something like a hunter if
you think of nimrod for example who who
was the the king of babel was the the
one who created the uh the tower babel
and the city
he was said to be a great hunter before
god and so there's a sense in which
that's an image of imperialism and you
see the same in the story of king saul
of course king saul is hunting david but
you can still understand but the image
of this of this very powerful masculine
figure that
that
is trying to
like pierce things that are outside and
join them into potential there's it
definitely has to do with war as well
like it has to do with
with war but at a not exactly at the
same level
[Music]
all right so
brother james
asks what is the symbolism of a live
broadcast more specifically what are the
symbols we should be looking
for to show us
the ultimate consequence of having
technologies where everyone in the world
could essentially watch the same thing
at the same time my instinct tells me
this is not a good thing that is somehow
it's leading to the end enter to
antichrist but i can't define it much
more than just this gut feeling that the
evolution of live broadcasting from
radio television to the internet is a
major factor in diminishing people's
ability to see the world symbolically
i'm hoping you have a clear view of this
thanks as always
well for sure a way
to understand i think the idea of live
broadcast or just broadcast in general
it really is
similar to what you said in the sense
that it is a it's moving
it's a way to move towards a kind of
mono culture too where the idea with the
idea that
the entire world
if you can imagine an event and there
have been events like that that are so
let's say 911 like you have an event
like that that's so
strong
that the entire world is watching it
like the whole world is seeing it
at the same time so on the one hand
there's like an insane unity but also a
weird flattening of reality where it's
like we all have this direct
it's indirect but like this
the sense that we're connected to an
event that's happening in the world and
the whole world is kind of connected to
that event um
i for some reason this the the image
that comes to mind is the image in
revelation of the
witnesses
um it says that the the the witnesses
will be
will be killed and something about how
like the whole world will see it like
the entire world will see
and will like their bodies will be like
displayed for the entire world to see
for for for a certain amount of time
and so
there's definitely something about that
like you said that's right
says
what would happen to a vampire if you
drank christ's blood dude what is this
he would explode he would he would
explode you know it says it says in
scripture that uh that uh
that you know when you come to communion
you know you come if you don't discern
the the blood uh body and blood of
christ then then it is to your
condemnation right and so i think if a
vampire drank the blood of christ he
would just
he would he would he would explode or or
he'd be saved but it just depends on the
reason why he did it but in the way a
vampire usually drinks the blood of
someone he would he would just uh that'd
be the end of that
the end of that vampire
okay so
all right so eric says
uh hi jonathan hope you're well in loris
arseny
claims and loris arseniy claimed not to
feel at home on his first visit to a
cathedral this beca this because god
seems
closer and warmer in orthodoxy and
higher and grander in catholicism could
you expand on this
um
man i think it has to do
with even just in terms of the
architecture i can understand what he
means that
you know gothic architecture is
something which is
pointing up right that it because it has
all these spires and all these points
all the windows all the the spires
everything is kind of elevating you up
towards heaven you could say
um and even into if you go inside a um
a cathedral a gothic attractor
especially and all the all these volts
and all this this vaulted ceiling is is
pointing is really kind of moving up
whereas
in
in um in orthodoxy in the orthodox
church
because of the square and dome
there's a it does feel like a closer
thing and also
the the walls in orthodox churches are
often painted with icons and so you you
come into a cloud of witnesses and
everything is
everything is presencing itself to you
and even in terms of let's say the image
of christ in the dome
um
you know it's up there
but it's also
there's it's also let's say that image
up there is also the same image that you
see on the iconostasis there's a sense
of of closeness which i think
which i think is
a sense of of family you know but you
know
i think these are tendencies because i
mean i'm sure if you go to hagia sofia
you probably feel the crazy grandeur of
that of that church i've never been
there but
i've been in massive orthodox churches
where you do feel that grandeur
so
but i know it i see what he means
in that sense
so wedge young men says is it true that
all dogs go to heaven and so there's so
many things wrong with that question
which
like
i could find at least two ways
you know three ways in which that
question is is a is it is not right so i
don't know how to answer it because it's
it's like go to heaven first of all you
know i don't talk about that and then
dogs and then all it's like all the dogs
go to heaven so
yeah all right
i mean in uh in scripture it says from
the new jerusalem it says that the
outside are the dogs in the uh and when
there's an image of the new jerusalem it
says it's like outsider are the dogs
from new jerusalem so you know
maybe some of them can stand as guards
and then and the new jerusalem
so pluma asks what is the significance
of joshua staying in the tent of meeting
even when moses leaves
i don't know i've never thought about
that
i'm sorry
maybe something to the effect that he's
going to enter into the into the holy
land
and not moses
something like that
that he's actually going to cross over
and not moses maybe something like that
jeffrenomic says greetings jonathan in
your last live stream on the symbolic
world facebook group you mentioned pavel
florensky and his book imaginaries in
geometry
your description
in of his conclusion was fascinating so
i impulse bought the book i studied
abstract math university and since being
introduced to the symbolic world i
struggled to see how mathematics can
meaningfully contribute to the symbolic
world project are you aware of any
similar works that the mathematically
inclined audience member would
appreciate
um
[Music]
i'm not a math person you might have to
ask my brother he would definitely know
he's far more of a mathematician
i know that i know that that uh guinoa
actually wrote an interesting little
book called against
against infantismal calculus
in which he argues
he argues that that uh
systems of proportions like fractions
uh
are are more real
than uh decimal points you know that
kind of stuff and how the decimal system
is really uh
like a it's like an aggression on
reality because it's like what does it
even mean right you know what
what what proportions are like half of
something you know etc but what are
these these points like point one two so
so so that might be an interesting book
to look into but i'm not a
not a math person
um
all right let's see what do we got
in the chat
so
so in the gospel christ expands his
following after healing the sick is that
an example of integrating a remainder
when we accept christ's healing is he
the remainder we are
integrating
um
so i don't think you're seeing it in the
right position i think you have to
understand
uh healing as
more related to forgiveness of sins
healing a body is is the
let's say physical equivalent of what
what forgiving sins is that is
it's a
it's like you have something
that isn't going working according to
its telos that isn't that isn't working
according to the way it should and then
you fix it
when you fix it then you you realign
things together you bring
[Music]
you know the different elements back
together in a proper order so i think
that that's really
how you have to understand uh
healing and so
the fact that that would then bring
people into
following him is not surprising because
the people following him and kind of
starting to form a body around him is
also an image of that healing of how
you know someone has some defective
aspect to them and then something which
isn't
working according to its purpose and
then christ kind of
resets it you know
um
[Music]
let's see all right so a popper asks
what does the pattern of repentance look
like and how does it break the pattern
of sin
and so
one of the things about sinning
is that it often it often involves
forgetting it it involves
there's a there's something we all often
have an idea that like when people sin
that that they're somehow
deciding to sin
and often that's not how it happens
often
when we sin it's like a forgetting a
forgetting of what's true and a
forgetting of a real purpose and
an attachment to lower desires
and so
what one of the things repentance does
is that
it first of all
makes you name the thing
so you name you name the the thing and i
mean we actually actually we even
sometimes repent for things that we
don't that we did unwittingly but
there's a sense in which
it's it's like a
it's a bringing forth of the problematic
aspect
in order to then
in order to then
heal it so you can understand it
something like um
you know you go to the doctor
and before the doctor heals you he's
gonna try to figure out what's wrong
with you like he can't heal you if he
doesn't figure out what's wrong with you
and so you have to be able to say it
hurts here or this is broken or whatever
and then we'll all agree that that's the
problem and so now we we are going to
heal it and so that's an aspect of
repentance which is
that you know we as we repent of the sin
we kind of shine a light on this the
thing that's off the path
then
uh
let's say
there's a man in which it restarts the
the possibility of realigning it
because
we've kind of exposed it and we're we
are
disassociating from it right we're
saying
i did this but i don't want this
right does that make sense so you you i
don't know you lie and you're like oh i
lied i just lied you're like okay i lied
but i don't want that and so i ask
forgiveness
and i repent of my lie
and so you can understand how doing that
doing that over and over and over
is actually a way to train you
to slowly move away from that thing
you know uh
yeah so
i don't know i to me that that that's
that's part of it at least you know
all right so let's see
michael o'connor says
gothic architecture is epic i think
garth i think architecture is epic too i
think that
gothic architecture is like the
if done properly it's like the best of
western christianity is gothic
architecture you know it's it really is
and you know in a way it has its own
characteristics which maybe need to be
balanced with
with with
you know the more
let's say uh like uh the more west
eastern architecture
but i think maybe the same too like
there's something about the gothic which
says something that's true like
standing in i don't know like standing
in in a gothic
uh
cathedral like standing in front of a
gothic basilica or gothic cathedral you
know i don't know how you could see that
there's not something true about that
space i mean
it's pretty amazing gothic architecture
is amazing it's very impressive it's
impressive in the sense that it does
create that sense of awe and that sense
of
of uh
transcendence which is which is part of
what christianity is you know there is a
sense in which god is you know we talk
about cataphatic and apophatic there's a
sense in which god is also always moving
beyond our representation beyond
everything so there's not there's not
nothing wrong with that if it's properly
balanced with the fact that christ is
also coming back down on us i think
again of the the eastern architecture
with christ in the dome that is
representing you know christ returning
into the world and christ kind of acting
as the
the king and the the one that's
presenting itself to us
um i think that those two things have uh
have a function
all right so sarah mary says hi jonathan
i was wondering if you could talk about
the symbolism of cats
it seems that they have lived with
humans for a very long time
they are canonically as i understand it
the only animals allowed behind the
akanestasis what
i'd never heard that before
they are
the center of various superstitions
across multiple ages and cultures people
have associated them with witches
and with good or bad luck and i read
once i read once that sailors used to
believe they controlled the weather with
their tails like dogs they are one of
the most common animals kept as pets in
modern times but they are in many ways
the opposite of dogs wondering what you
think thank you
uh
i mean there's definitely something
going on with like especially even in
the modern times the manner in which
we've set up an opposite between dogs
and cats right who set up this sense
even that they are like dog people and
cat people it's definitely manifesting
something about reality something about
different types of humans different
types of
aspects of humanity one which is maybe
let's say on the positive side
uh more
reserved more crafty wiser maybe
um but on the negative side maybe
possibly hypocritical possibly
uh
you know a trick tricky in that sense uh
and then a dog which is obviously more
obvious and more
you know
not secretive like a cat is and is more
obvious and more outgoing but is also
is also maybe can feel a little
too much like a little too obvious and a
little too present like a little too
much in your in your face uh and so i
don't know i mean but there's definitely
something going on in the modern world
in terms of the relationship between
you know people who love dogs and people
love cats and and how they see each
other as opposites um in terms of the
ancient world i never heard that the
idea that they are allowed beyond the
iconostasis
um
for sure they they are an image of
discretion and there's a secretive
aspect to cats
for sure
and i mean that might explain something
to do with you know maybe why cats were
venerated
in in
places like egypt or whatever that they
that there was something about their
secretive type of um
their secretive aspect that was yeah
that had something to do so
so i see people like fighting
fighting in the uh in the chat like cats
are evil dogs are good
someone says god's cat when
that's hilarious
oh my goodness
all right here we go so lisa says can
you elaborate on your post post to the
facebook group about the giants in the
book of enoch being as tall as those are
300 cubits in length someone commented
that the ark is our boat but their
coffin is that right and why
specifically the number 300
um
i don't really think i understand why
it's 300 i think i'm sure matsuya would
definitely have insight about that but
the the fact that they're related in
terms of
in terms of uh
their length i think it has to do with
something to the effect that noah is
using
an aspect of the giants
in order to
build the ark i've hinted at that a few
times before you know you know that
there's something about no one it is
pointed at in different ways in the
traditions you know first of all the
idea that he uses technology which is
from the descent from kane's lineage in
order to
create the ark is already a surprising
thing like he he basically you know in
scripture it suggested and especially in
the enoch traditions that
the technification of the world
is one of the things that brought about
the the flood and and the corruption so
the fact that noah is using that
knowledge and kind of flipping it in a
way that he'll use it as a
as a vehicle you know and it's related
also to the idea of like a holy ab which
means something like the
bezel i think
sorry bezel which means something like
the darkness of god the one who who who
built the um the ark of the covenant and
the tabernacle
and there are other traditions that
suggest that for example noah married
um
twowell kane's sister nama
and
and so
that there's some lin there's something
of kane in
the
in the in the ark and there's something
of the giants
um
and so you can see like they're all
these weird legends that try to hint at
that there are other weird legends about
how one of the giants og these are
jewish legends that one of the giants og
you know like either
he he rode on the on the side of the ark
or that he
also uh wrote a unicorn like there's a
weird legend weird jewish legend about
how ogg wrote a unicorn behind the ark
um and so
it's like all these things that are kind
of trying to
help us understand
you know ultimately which i think is
leading us to something like the
symbolism of the new jerusalem where
that lineage of cain
gets
transformed and brought back like the
garments of death are re-transformed
into garments of glory
something like that so uh so yeah i mean
it has to do with death turning death
against death that's for sure
that's how i understand that
um and so on patreon we're moving to
patreon and so bradley says it's death
defeating death yeah that's pretty much
it
all right nate barker says hey jonathan
some passages in scripture make it seem
like christ the apostles and the
earliest christians were under the
impression that the second coming was
happening very soon for example when
thessalonians 4 13 18 paul seems to
think within his lifetime or very soon
after what do you say to this and why
hasn't christ returned after so long
when scripture makes it seems like his
return is imminent that's because his
return is imminent you know
what i'm going to tell you christ is
returning soon so get ready be ready for
christ's return that's all i can say to
that
all right so here we go yah israel says
hi jonathan i'm a new supporter i love
your ethiopian series and was wondering
what your take on the symbology of
rastafari movement and emperor haley
selassie one is
home i know many people including myself
who have been introduced to orthodoxy
and developed interest in it through
reading about emperor haley selassie
thank you for your work really enriching
stuff for the mind and soul
blessings from scotland and so
i mean
obviously
i would say that there are some aspects
of the rastafarian
religion that are obviously like super
weird i mean
but there's an idea in rastafarianism
there's an idea which actually i think
seems to
interestingly interestingly pan out like
there's something about the death of
haley selassie
that marks a
transition in the world and there's
something about the figure of [ __ ]
selassie which marks a and it's not just
the the death of [ __ ] solasi there's the
death of hai salasi and there's also the
death uh you know of uh
of of the tsar of the chara during the
communist revolution there's something
about
that which seems to mark the end of uh
of a world
and you know
so there's something very
there's something very interesting about
him and about his role it seems in
the the kind of end of the ancient world
and this weird
this weird modern reality this weird
disenchanted and kind of uh modern
reality in which we
in which we are in and so i think that
definitely holly selassie
has a uh
has an interesting position in that
story
you know there are really fascinating
stories about how
during the
um during the during the the
just like before world war one and
during the time of the
the the this last there was this last
kind of effort by
the different powers in in
the christian powers to kind of unite
and to
create a common front and this was
headed
in some part by people like tsar
nicholas and and holly selassie and so
they would actually have these meetings
where you know all these kings of europe
and these christian leaders would meet
together these christian aristocrats um
and what was interesting is that
this is someone told me this i i don't
know if it's true i never ch fact
checked it okay but this is a story that
i was told by andrew gould by the way
and so andrew told me about how
during these these events where all the
you know the king of england and the
king of and the tsar the tsar of russia
and all these christian leaders would
meet is that because they were they
would have these formal events and
formal processions and everything they
had to decide like who
who would be in the first and the second
and the third in these processions and
in these these
entries and they decided to do it based
on
the uh how ancient their
dynasty was
you know and so holly selassie would
always be the first
because you know according to ethiopian
tradition you know it's like his
the dynasty is like thousands of years
old and it's like he's actually like the
you know he's actually the descendant of
solomon in there in their tradition and
so it's just interesting okay it would
have been a really interesting time to
to be there with all these like these
last christian kings you know and
yeah yeah
um all right so
okay sorry so let's see
okay so brandon burns asks what is the
symbolism of the leprechaun and so the
little symbolism of the leprechaun is
the symbolism of ireland you know it's
like that's what it is
the symbolism of the
leprechaun is the symbolism of the
monster
at the end of the rainbow
you know
who hides the treasure and you can
understand if you want to kind of
understand the function that ireland has
had in
you know
preserving christian
wisdom and even roman wisdom
in a time of darkness
it's like that's what
ireland
was you know that's what ireland that's
the role that ireland played so i think
that the leprechaun is like a like a
weird manifestation of
this weird this strange exception on the
edge of the world which ends up being a
treasure chest
for
the spiritual wisdom and the you know
the spiritual
uh the mystical
tradition of the of of christianity so
super yeah that's what i think
leprechauns are
um
so christian swenson asked what is the
symbolic meaning of atlantis and so i
think the symbolic meaning of atlantis
is just one of the versions of the flood
story that it it's a it's the version of
the idea of an old world
that
was flooded that fell into the ocean and
then it's gone so we don't have access
we don't have access to that world
anymore it's just too far far away from
us
and so that's what i think that's what i
think atlantis is just another version
of of that of a pre-deluvian world but
now a myth taken from
taken from the greek point of view
all right so
tom again says can the metaverse be used
for good or can it only be an attempt to
escape from the real world if a good
metaverse were to be built what would it
look like
i mean the answer to that is whatever it
is now like the metaverse is already
there it's it's not like it's just not
totally unified so
i don't think that it's evil in itself
but i do think that it's extremely
dangerous just like twitter is extremely
dangerous just like
just like facebook's extremely dangerous
but maybe let's say times
times another 10.
um
and so the the difficulty with the
metaverse and these inner this stuff
even now look what i'm doing now is that
there's a manner in which it is
disincarnated and
so so we have to be careful not to
confuse this with true
true communion you know and true
relationships so you watch you guys
watching me answer questions this is not
but this is a this is a diminished
version of
of human relationships and although it's
powerful because i can i can reach a lot
of people and i can say a lot of things
to a lot of people uh it is it is a
diminishing inequality necessarily and
so the metaverse
is going to be that as well now the
problem with the metaverse of course
is
it's trying to be immersive and it's all
it's trying to replace
true it's trying to
to pose as real relationships and pose
as real communion and so i think that
that's definitely
uh a problem something which will lead
people into great despair if they
if they
accept that like if they take that
seriously
they'll be very
very they'll become very miserable their
people will be miserable in the
metaverse they'll just you know like how
the internet is kind of ruining people's
mental health now i mean the metaverse
it's going to be way more uh it's going
to be very dangerous and also because
it's going
the way that the metaverse sets itself
up is like almost like a
you know like a
infinite desire and so like think of a
think of someone
who has who like lives in like a like a
weird furry type character who has their
digital avatar and you know they
fantasize about their avatar and they
have this and so there's something
really weird and unhealthy about that
but you know or someone who's really
obsessed with some massive video game
and creates their avatar in the video
game you know takes all their time to
create their avatar and then kind of
sees it as an extension of themselves uh
but now imagine that but now with
goggles and you can look down at
yourself and you can see yourself as
this
as this avatar a man
so it is it is definitely dangerous um
but i think that
yeah i i don't know i don't know it's
like i don't know when the moment to
back away from it is i don't know
because
do we need people planting seeds in the
metaverse
yeah of course i just like
in a way youtube
is a tool that is work that is actually
bringing
helping people kind of
move on a trail back to real communion
maybe the metaverse will be that as well
but i i don't know like
it's for sure
it's very it seems like i've never tried
it like i never put on the goggles to
enter into these kinds of worlds but it
seems like it could be extremely
intoxicating and difficult to kind of
keep your
keep your
yourself straight through all that
all right
hey
eric hensey says what are good
indicators to check
pattern recognition against confirmation
bias
um
so
there's a few ways to do it one one is
of course
to see if it matches with
other what other people have said you
know if there's some corollary with what
other people have said another way to
understand
is whether or not you can find other
examples of the pattern that you're
talking about
and
do you have to ignore massive aspects of
the way something presents itself to you
in order to
to interpret it
a good a good um example of that is
you know you see that all the time
people interpret
people interpret video movies or i've
seen it even people now interpreting
like my comic book our comic book that's
been out now is that people get hyper
focused on the detail and then they they
kind of stop seeing how that detail is
actually integrated into
[Music]
other aspects of the story and so you
know you see that when people interpret
movies they look at they watch the movie
and then they catch some reference to
something else and they're like aha and
then they jump into it but they
they stop to see how these are all
things that are connected together
so i think that that's
that's those are ways to avoid uh
confirmation bias
being part of a tradition in general is
a good way to avoid confirmation bias
because that the mechanism has
worked itself out you know where
you know there's a reason for the
patterning i could say in christianity
it's not if there's there's a reason for
the patterning which is also to kind of
bring you to transform you into
something more it's not just about
it's not just about pattern recognition
um
yeah but i think those are those are
good ways
and also ultimately symbolism has to
talk about a higher structure it has to
fractively lead you up
towards something else and so
if your symbolic structures and symbolic
interpretations are leading you down
then
i would always be cautious
about that
you know
sometimes it can show you some aspects
of what's going down here but
you know a good example is the is the
is the ufo thing right the uf it's like
people who see ufos everywhere people
who look at every traditional
imagery they can find as soon as they
see us disc or circle they're like ha
flying saucer right you know
and so it's like what does that tell you
about reality like what does seeing
flying saucers everywhere
in ancient art
tell you about how to exist in the world
it doesn't it's like a weird thing about
information that's hidden in these
things and you know if you can decode it
in a way then it will
i don't even know what it's supposed to
do like who cares if they're like
why would that matter you know uh so i
think that that's that's a good way if
if
if let's say you you're interpreting
everything
to know like whether or not lizard
people rule the world or something like
that then it's like
i mean i would say it's like try to
understand what the idea that people
think like
why do people think that ufos are
important is a better way to understa to
think about ufos or why do people how do
people even come up with a theory about
like how lizard people rules the world
that's more important than
trying to look in every movie and find
traces of like the lizard people and and
you know
you know what i mean i hope people
understand what i mean so i would say
that direction
and then tradition
and uh and also notice making sure that
your interpretation is coherent with
interpretations that have come before
you
so corey coble says that's maybe the
problem with the metaverse it's
structured in a specific format it's
designed to addict to make people
money prioritize pure sharing of
information yeah exactly that makes
sense like you can understand that
the very purpose of metaverse is just to
turn you into a product and so already
it's like that's a problem so
um
but like i said i don't think that it
doesn't mean that there would be
something to do there but it would have
to be thought out and would have to be
you'd have to be cautious and not and
not de-sacralize
um
so jokubas wrote and says what is the
symbolism of boiling a child in the
mother's milk is it related to spoiling
so this refers to a law
in the old testament where it says that
you should not boil a kid in its
mother's milk that is you shouldn't yeah
so you shouldn't eat the meat of a
animal that is cooked in the milk of the
mother
and so
this is really
this is really
has to do with all these laws that try
to preserve normal causality right and
try to preserve regular causality
of
so
this has to do with incest it it's a
it's the same type of law that has to do
with not engaging in incest which is a
breakdown of of causality so you have
you know your father you have a father
and a mother and you have children and
then those children marry and then they
have children but if if if a father like
has a child with their grandchild then
all of a sudden
the relationship of causality is
completely broken the normal
so so so the father right so the father
is both the grandfather and the child
and then becomes the brother
the step-brother of this one and that
you know it's like all the entire world
starts to break down into chaos and so
the idea of not using
something which is meant to feed
the
child
uh
use that to kill and to to cook
the the child so it's like that which is
life-giving to the child you don't want
to use that as the means by which to
kill it and to and to then
you know so
you could say that
the right order
is that you you can eat a child and its
mother's milk but you would eat you
would eat the kid
after it's
because it drank from his mother it got
the milk from its mother integrated into
its body then you eat the the kid and
that's the proper way to integrate both
at the same time it's integrated
fractally but when you do this that's
when you break down the normal causality
so a good way to understand it is you
know people wonder about these laws like
what is up with all these laws
what's important to understand in these
types of laws it's something like
pattern
enacting patterns
and
and so when you do these things i mean
christians don't do this but let's say
these types of laws when you do them you
are
even unconsciously engaging in modes of
being where you recognize levels of
causality
actively not in your mind not in the not
in just thinking but in doing it you
know you realize it you have to keep
wool and linen uh separate you can't
weave them together so what is going on
you understand that there's our
there are different categories of beings
that have to be kept separate to a
certain extent there are different
generations of of of realities that have
to be kept separate and if you confuse
them
then you create you break down the world
so doing it in practice
creates a pattern
of of behavior it's
i've mentioned this before it's like
you tell your child to shake someone's
hand you say you when you meet someone
you know you stand there you look them
in the eye you shake their hand and so
you would you could say the same you
would say why why would you why is
touching someone's hand something that
matters like why is it that you're
telling your child that when they meet
someone to touch their hand what kind of
what kind of nonsense is that but what
you realize is that
if the child learns to do that
properly and to take the time to look
the person in the eye to shake their
hands properly to engage with them
directly at a certain distance with a
certain firmness with a certain uh
rhythm then that will leak into all
their other behavior with people it will
create it will become a pattern
especially with a greeting it's like
when you first encounter someone here's
how you set the pattern of behavior
between you and them and then that will
then will have repercussions into
other aspects
of how you engage with people so that's
how a lot of these laws function there's
nothing weird about it we have a bunch
of these types of laws ourselves we just
don't realize them because we take the
idea of shaking someone's hand
so much for granted that we don't
realize that it's a patterning of
behavior
according to
certain
principles of how the world works so you
know
all right
all right here we go continuing on we
have to continue because we're about
halfway through
so anthony ross rosa says to what extent
should we practice these laws today
and so
as a christian there's a transformation
that happens
for sure in the in the laws and so
it's the emphasis is not exactly the
same
the emphasis in christianity ends up
being
a lot more in relationship to others in
relationship to people and so
and so i would say
as a christian you should you should
just follow christian behavior
um and and a lot of these laws
especially the purity laws of the old
testament are pretty much they pretty
much fall apart um
in christianity also because we are not
we are the strangers
most of us at least are we are the
strangers in that story so
all right drew mcmahon asked hi jonathan
my question is on the topic of free will
in your interview with robert read love
about bitcoin you talked about free will
and made the point you've made before
that the only genuine free will
uh to move free will move ultimately is
in the movement
in the moment move towards god that
everything else is contingent on
circumstances and other forces you may
not be aware of isn't one's choice in
the moment to move towards god still
impacted by those same forces and
circumstances i'm wondering how that
choice in particular is different than
all others which makes it actually free
versus all others which are contingent
thank you
and so once again it's like
there is no such thing as
we have to understand freedom
as
okay so understand freedom as that which
moves away
from uh
enslavement to the contingencies
and move towards the talos so it doesn't
mean that it's not framed by the
contingencies right of course it's like
you're not
you're not you're not free to
you're not free to eat salt
when you're
taking your shower like you're not free
to i'm trying to find the absurd
connections like you're not you know
you're not free to
you're not free to build a house when
you're you know when you're driving your
car it's like
the the reality has its contingencies
but
the freedom is when those contingencies
come together towards the purpose
and so that's the that's the freedom we
have is the freedom we have is to move
towards purpose move towards logos
that's the freedom and as you do that
you you become less burdened by it's not
that the contingencies aren't there is
that the talos enlightens them like
casts light on them you don't
feel them as contingencies as much you
see them as the frame in which to move
towards purpose and so i think that
that's the way to understand freedom
there
i don't think any other way to
understand freedom works
it's not it's just not uh
it just doesn't work and so
so you can imagine that let's say as you
right so think of it like as you
move up so let's say you you discover
the logos of a specific thing and you
discover the purpose and you move
towards that purpose
and then that is that is embedded into
all these other purposes and as you move
higher up
then all those purposes
all those contingencies
kind of fall away
it's not that they actually end up
ceasing to exist
but it's that they don't appear
as they appear as these glorious points
that are kind of moving up
towards the ultimate purpose and as you
move towards theosis itself then the
whole world starts to
shine with that one final purpose which
is
you know to exist in love in the
you know in the life of god something
like that and then
then then er then you're free
you're not free in the sense that you're
not free in the sense that
like let's say when faced with a glass
of water you're like well i don't want
to drink
water right i want to
i don't know i like i don't want to
drink water i i want to do a cartwheel
and it's like i don't want to drink you
know i don't it's like no you you you
engage the world with a with a
transparent
vision and and
understanding and participation in the
purposes of things
and so you're not a slave anymore and
you could be you could be put in prison
you could be you could be shackled to
the wall you could be tortured you could
anything could be done to you and you
wouldn't always be free
because you would not be
a slave to the contingency because you
would be living up in that higher
purpose
so i don't see how
without understanding freedom that way
that the christian world makes sense
like
if freedom is just this idea of a lack
of contingency then
what does that have to do with a martyr
like what does that have to do with
someone who is led into being eaten by
the lions the images of the martyrs are
there to show us that if you live in the
highest
telos with the highest purpose
then no matter what happens to you down
here you will be free not because you
won't not because you
you won't be in the contingencies
because the contingencies are inevitable
it's that those contingencies won't
swallow you they won't
they won't hold your being
i hope that makes sense
i always feel sometimes with these
questions that i'm actually being
confusing to people
um so andrei andrei b says it's
difficult to understand you use on
angels really
the way you describe the angel of a city
in scientific terms is reasonable but
could you use similar terms to talk
about gabriel who told mary she is going
to give birth to jesus
i mean i don't know what to what to what
to answer that
it's like
do you think that
let's say uh
your being
is reasonable in terms of science like
you you existing and being able to
communicate and being able to
act in the world
uh is reasonable and i i hope you would
say yes
and so
when i use the image of a city
and and the idea of an angel that has a
city as a body you could say
it's it's just to help you understand
how you can perceive that but there are
other methods of causality
by which higher beings can manifest
themselves
and some of them are possibly more
subtle
than then a city you know so so think of
it like the virtues like the virtues the
body of the virtues or the kingdom of
the virtues if you haven't the you know
the angel of
of of a virtue then those angels have
far more subtle bodies the way in which
they interact with the world is is not
the same as a as the city a city is
easier to understand but in terms of
these other types of beings that exist
the way in which they manifest
themselves is more subtle so the idea
that there are
that there are
let's say uh
angels archangels and especially the
notion of let's say gabriel and michael
as these kind of two
two sides of
of the man which god manifest himself in
the world like you know the blue angel
and the red angel or the
the the angel of the right hand and the
angel of the left hand that you kind of
see in in
gabriel and michael
um
i mean i don't know why that i don't
know why that's to me that's not
bothersome at all now whether or not i
can know
the mechanical causation by which
gabriel manifested himself to
to marry i don't know i'm not there like
i didn't have that experience
in a way it doesn't totally matter to
understand what are the
mechanical causations by which that that
happened the mechanical causes by which
mary understood
that she had been contacted by an angel
i don't know what that experience is
um
i mean she might have had a vision
and that maybe no one else could have
seen the vision that she saw but the
vision was nonetheless real and the
vision was nonetheless true and so you
know gabriel is using her mechanisms of
perception
through which to manifest himself to
to her right you have an example of that
you know in the story of uh of balum and
the ass where
where baum is is going is you know is
going down the road with his donkey
and he can't see the angel the the the
donkey can see the angel but he can't
see the angel so it's a funny story and
then the donkey is trying to save balum
moving off the
moving off the the
the road and so and then all of a sudden
michael decides that he's going to
manifest himself to
to bala the angel decides to manifest
himself to balo and so then balance sees
the angel so these are so what is the
mechanical causation of that like what
is
i don't know like i mean i don't know
it's like
it's not that's not the way traditional
stories and these types of things don't
they don't describe that because they
don't really care um but i mean the
reason why i use city all the time is
just because it's a lot easier to
understand with the city
uh how some how phenomena can gather
under a principality
and then manifest you know a higher will
into the world
um but there are a lot of other ways
that that can happen so you know
hope that makes sense
so reuben korff says hi jonathan in
exploring early christian universal
history i've encountered what seems to
be an odd mix of symbolism that is
many early church fathers connected the
giants and titans of
greek myth
with the human builders of the tower of
babel yep
that is that chaotic and wild figures
were the architects of the archetypal
bastion of hyper order of the ancient
world this seems confused or at least
confusing to me how should i understand
this
um so
it's not that it's not that hard to
understand
that they
there's a sense in which nimrod is a
continuation of the nephilim and this is
something which is not i mean like i
said in the story it doesn't tell you
how that happens people try to find all
kinds of weird ways to try to connect
the nephilim in the old testament to
let's say nimrod in in the in the new
testament
uh neuron no after the flood sorry the
the the the pre-diluvian uh giants and
the nimrod but there's definitely a
connection between nimrod and the the
giants like that he just was a giant so
there's a sense in which
the the i mean if you want to get
nitty-gritty with it you can understand
the way father stephen uh presents it in
the lord of spirits which is that you
know there is a there is a ritual
to embody
higher beings and mix them or connect
them with humans and to make humans the
the
place of embodiment for these these
higher
these fallen angels or these gods that
that mix with humans
and that and that's what a lot of this
is about you know that that they after
the flood they somehow
did it again like they somehow continued
to to
embody these principalities in humans
and that would create these demigods
that were
extremely powerful extremely influential
that had that had more power to them and
were also the founders of of
civilizations the founder of technical
societies remember again that the cities
are based in kane so nimrod building a
great city after the flood is a
repetition right of the problem of cain
in the in the pre-diluvian world
so
that's the way to understand it so you
can
so you can see how
the church fathers would connect
the the titans
and the the giants with
that in the bible which was representing
the same thing
which was representing the same
the same notion
um
so i think that that's that's the best
way of of understanding it
and so
you know it's
the in the book of enoch what it
describes you could you could then put
it into the greek world and think about
the same thing you know you have these
gods that come down and have
relationships with women and then they
produce children that become
these very very powerful figures that
are terrible and that you know are the
founders of civilizations and whatnot
um
so
yeah so think about it like gilgamesh
was a demigod for example and gilgamesh
you know is another example of this kind
of stuff
i'm probably going to do a talk i did a
talk last week at a college here about
the relationship between the book of
enoch
and um let's say technology and the
environmental narrative crisis narrative
and so i might do an english version of
that for my channel if people are
interested in that might do that
so
julius richards should we not
participate in a movie fandom
uh
i would say it's probably better to
avoid it you know i mean
especially like the more active parts of
it i would be careful it's okay to be
fans of things like it's okay to enjoy
things i think it's always a it's always
about the place that they have in your
life you know if you
if you spend all your time thinking
about star trek and you know and you
don't
and you you live in the star trek world
then i think that's a problem i mean if
you things are properly ordered and and
you think star trek is interesting and
maybe can help you understand certain
aspects of the world and how the world
works that um
that doesn't take over your your your
being then i think that's fine
um
so you know
all right so christian klice asked hello
jonathan what is your favorite american
folk hero
paul bunyan johnny appleseed john henry
i don't really have one
i really like i definitely like the
story of john henry i like it because
i think it it does kind of represent the
tragedy of of uh
of our situation you know you think the
story think of let's say
uh
of our own situation as the problem of
john henry think of like i always kind
of joke
i can i can think of someone like like
elon musk is like john henry who finally
gave in you know he's arguing he's like
he's telling people to be careful about
artificial intelligence and finally he's
like you know what if we can't can't
beat him join them you know
um
[Music]
so yeah for sure in our case the story
of john henry will be important as we
realize
that we're being
becoming irrelevant to the machine you
know and be be attentive to that
all right dorothea says the conception
of christ the virgin birth connected to
lowering heaven down and the assumption
of the mother of god to rising earth up
and is it connected to the different
roles men and women have in the church
that have women being lowering the
heavens through prayer and the role of
men
being rising the earth through the
sacraments
hmm
yeah i'm not totally sure
about the second part but definitely the
first part
is right and also
not only is the first part right but i
would say that you really have to
understand so there's an image in the
orthodox tradition you know which is the
dormition of the mother of god so you
see the mother of god
you know uh dead
on uh
you know lying down and you see all
all the disciples around her and you see
people
sensing around her
and then in the middle you have christ
with the the soul of the mother of god
in his arms
so i think that that if you kind of
understand that as the totality of the
story which in a certain manner let's
say the assumption of the mother of god
and you know the the deification of the
mother of god
and the incarnation are
intimately related it's like
in the incarnation is contained
you know the final
uh you know the final rising up of the
saints you know meeting christ up in the
heavens that you see in the book of
revelation that that
you know and that this is
this is relate all of these are kind of
related so the idea of like the heavenly
jerusalem coming down
is is also at the same time right the
earth meeting it and so those two
movements of the incarnation and the
assumption of the virgin they seem to be
two aspects of
a same cosmic mystery
you know
that's the way that i see it you know
the idea that right right i mean it's
there like i'm saying this is some big
mystery it's right there in the the
saying that that we that we have all the
time the saint athanasia is saying that
you know the
that god became man so that man would
become god like that's it it's those two
things happening at the same time and
you see that both in the incarnation and
in the assumption
uh
and the the and the deification of the
virgin as being
a kind of grand story version of that
short that little statement you know
oh yeah i by the way brad i hear brad
you have covet dude i hope you have the
mild version i hope you're okay
i mean it seems like right now mostly
the mild version is what's left and so
if you have the omicron and it's the
other variants it's actually i keep
telling people like omicron is like a
blessing if you get omicron get omicron
i had i had the delta version which was
really not fun
and i feel like i still have some
i still have some like remainders of
that which is
now you know more than six months ago so
if you can get if you can get omicron
like run out and get it like man people
are gonna shut me down youtube's gonna
shut me down for saying that but like
would be a good idea to get that
bradley says i wanted the higher dose
delta
you want to prove your masculinity out
only a minor cleansing of my sins all
right all right so let's get back to
this okay so anders vrostad said hi
jonathan what is the symbolism of tears
and what does sangrego of nisa mean by
for tears are the unfailing guardian
of those saved by virtue
and so i think that
i mean the way to unders it's not any
tears by the way but really it is in a
way
tears of compassion for others and tears
of contrition for yourself
uh those are the salvific tears and so
there's a there's a manner in which
compassion for others
is
is a immediate
connection so you cry
for others then you
are living in them like you know they're
they're living in you and you're living
in them there's a way in which the
barriers
get get broken down
um
and so i think that that's
and there's a way in which there's a
there's a surprising thing about that
which is that
there's actually a way in which
having compassion for others
is the only way
to manifest the proper relationships of
hierarchy which is that
there's like a weird secret about
having compassion for others which is
that
in order to have compassion for all men
you kind of have to be above
you have to be high up
you have to be able to perceive the
suffering of all and you have to be able
to
to to connect to all this suffering
so there's a manner in which it's the
way to be above in the hierarchy without
the dangers of
being above in the hierarchy without the
danger of being above
being high up and lording over others
is the gift of tears and the gift of
tears can be an image of someone who's
really high up in the hierarchy of being
and that is manifesting itself through
infinite compassion
um
maybe that's the best way to understand
that
so
sean rigaldo says what's your process
when writing do you have any tips in
regard to symbolic writing
i mean my process when writing
is is probably not the best process i'm
going to have to change that soon
because if i'm going to write an actual
book
i'm uh i'm very intuitive when i write
and i usually don't make a plan and i
just start writing and then i just write
um
and
i try not to be too judgmental when i'm
writing i just kind of
let things connect
and uh and then i do a lot of editing
that's the way that i write and i do a
lot of editing because i come back and
then i
i
put things back together and i
i work on the language and the
formulations but at first it's really
just trying to get the image all the
images out and the stories out so in
terms of symbolic writing in terms of
writing about symbolism
you know i wouldn't have any other tips
besides the one that would be just in
general interpreting symbolism which is
that i think the best thing to do is to
stay as close as possible
to your subject at first
stay within the thing you're you're
you're interpreting
uh and then once you
you've got that mastered then start to
apply it analogically for people to be
able to see how it connects
um
but at first try to stay
as close as possible to what you're
you're doing
and one of the examples i i always tell
people try like the way i do it if you
notice when i talk about symbolism i'll
often give like a really like a biblical
type example like a kind of high example
and then i'll try to give a very basic
one with you know like you know how you
put your socks on in the morning or some
really basic basic thing to try to show
or to try to test for myself even how
the thing i'm intuiting
properly connects to the different
levels of of reality
so um
so that's some that's advice for that
all right so dusan babic says why is
national identity so important in
orthodoxy is there any deeper meaning of
national identity from the perspective
of eschaton or is it just a consequence
of having churches tied to specific
people language
i think it definitely is i think it
definitely is linked to eschaton and it
definitely is linked to
um
to a proper embodiment of
the logos across all the different
levels
and so this is something which
right now is kind of in conflict because
a lot of people
in the orthodox church and especially
the orthodox church in america for
reason
because
in america because a lot of the national
orthodox groups are in exile from their
own nation
then they bring that into american
orthodoxy which means that american
orthodoxy can
very difficult and
is struggling to find its own reality
like it's it's struggling to find its
own existence
and this is because
and so it creates a weird situation
right orthodox in america is a is this
is a scandal to be honest in terms of
its structure which is that we have
these different bishops for every
jurisdiction in every city this is not
how orthodoxy should be there should be
you know one structure in a in a land
and one bishop for a city or like that's
the ideal but obviously it can't always
play out but like that there's one bit
that everybody
that goes to church in one area has the
same bishop that's what it should be in
orthodoxy
but because of the the national problem
then it's so i understand why a lot of
people object to it but
nonetheless
in the in the description of the of the
heavenly jerusalem it says that
the heavenly jerusalem
is is there and is and is open
and the kings of all nations
carry their glory
into
to participate in the new jerusalem so
there's a sense in which the best of all
our identities at every level in which
those manifest
is to be given up to god and participate
in this kind of eschatological
fractal
final reality you could say um and so if
you watch my talk with uh aiden hart he
mentions that
you know the idea that
one of the things you have to do if
you're an englishman is to be the best
englishman you can be
and that's part of
you participating in this liturgical
dance and so it's like i'm a father i'm
supposed to be the best father i can be
i'm part of a community i'm supposed to
be the best member of that community i
can be
um
always understanding that that all of
those kind of collapse into christ
ultimately all these identities collapse
into christ but that they they have
their
reality at the level in which they are
you know a lot of people use that verse
which says you know there's neither
greek nor jew there's neither slave nor
free to basically collapse all the
levels of reality and i think that
that's definitely the wrong way to do it
and i think that it's
it's a it's a modern it's a
it's kind of a weird modern way of of
using that verse
it it really is more of how all these
identities will
lose their particularity as you move
into christ so there's a man in which
you can move into christ and find
perfect unity of all the multiplicity
but that to the level that i am a father
and to the level that i am a canadian
and i am a man and i am all these things
then i need to live that to its highest
purpose you know
yeah
that's the best way i see it
so alicia murtha says i'm new to your
channel so forgive me if you previously
previously covered this what is the
relationship between symbolism
superstition and conspiracy theory it
seems like these can easily be conflated
and often are today how can we best
distinguish between them and ensure we
aren't fluctuating between them
so
i mean the first thing to say is
the first thing to say is that
the idea that there are no conspiracies
is is is is a uh is a political tool
there are conspiracies there are
the the fact that the difference between
understanding that there are
conspiracies there they're definitely
conspiracies there are conspiracies
multiple conspiracies which conspiracy
just means there are people that have
joined together and have a
have a goal and are trying to enact that
goal in the world you know
their purpose and so they conspire
together to do something so there are
plenty of conspiracy theories
conspiracies in the world now the
problem that happens with the conspiracy
theorists the way that like the one
that's completely unhinged you could say
is that
they see everything
as related to this
pattern of behavior in the world
and so
they're not looking at to what the
meanings of things are as they move up
the hierarchy of being but they're only
seeing
these different coded meanings as an
example of
conspiratorial action in the world so
what do i mean exactly by that
usually that type of thinking comes
about
when you don't believe the world
actually has meaning when you think that
the world is arbitrary so
some people who think that the world is
arbitrary and think that the world
doesn't naturally
manifest itself in meaning when they see
meaning in the world then they think
that that meaning had to be put there
by someone for a reason
and so then they look at the world and
they see all these patterns they see
these relationships between like stories
and they they see how this and that like
different religion tradition this or
that god looks like her
this story and this movie looks like
this story in this movie and they think
haha someone
put that there
to control us to manipulate us to do
that now it doesn't mean that people
don't put things in movies to control
you or to manipulate you of course they
do
you know
anybody who thinks differently is has
deluded to how the world works
so i think that
symbolism
what it what it does is that it
understands that these patterns are
natural first of all they're natural in
the world they can be manipulated they
can be used for purposes but they are
they will inevitably happen in the world
so the fact of noticing patterns
doesn't mean
that someone
like uh like a a human agent put it
there
it just it's it's there
and so
and the world works
rhymes like the world actually rhymes
reality rhymes reality is patterned
and so and then also those patterns
scale up towards higher and higher
understandings and participations in
reality so when someone
sees symbolism
only as a way that proves some phenomena
in the world where their symbolism isn't
moving up higher then that's when
there's a problem
uh right the example i gave before is
one of the best examples it's like
ufos they're your aliens they're aliens
so then everything becomes about showing
so every story every myth everything
is only there to talk about how they are
aliens
and it's like that's not helping you
like even if there are aliens it's not
helping you it's not helping you
understand
how this patterned world kind of exists
um
so in terms of superstition
um once again like i would also be
careful like
often
hidden in what we call superstition is
often
some meaningful stuff now i'm not saying
that i
i'm not saying that it's like if i see a
black cat across the road that i'm gonna
freak out or whatever or if i you know
if i
but there's if you analyze superstitions
maybe i should do it one day and with
you guys and get a bunch of
superstitions and then help you
understand why that pattern of
being would coalesce into a story and
why that story would be able to
keep people's attention over several
generations and you could maybe
understand how some of these
superstitions sometimes hide a nugget of
um
some very
powerful nuggets about how the world
works in story world so uh we could do
that maybe one day that might be fun um
all right so charlie longoria asked
hello jonathan i've been thinking about
the relationship between the theotokos
and the cherubim and seraphim
in literally in our prayers when we say
she is more honorable than the cherubim
and beyond compare more glorious than
the seraphim what is happening there
i have a protecting veil of the
theotokos icon and she is surrounded by
seraphims
yeah well for sure like when you see the
the mother of god surrounded by angels
you have to understand that in a way she
is
like the ark of the covenant we often
have the two angels when you see two
angels above in an icon next to the
mother of god often either christ or the
mother of god it has to do with this
idea of the two cherubs that are
covering the ark and so
um
you know
you could say that she has become the
the the she has become the
the container of the divine in the world
and so that's why she
contains all of creation in in her womb
i don't know how to say it that's why
she's higher than the seraphim and the
and the cherubim like she contained in
her
that which the con that that which the
universe could not contain and so she
becomes
you know
she becomes in a way
like an image of how we can also
go up and so it's like it's not just her
like there's a sense in which
we are in a certain manner meant to rule
over the angels like the man humans are
meant to rule over the angels and so the
the idea of the
this is like this is a
this is a complicated thing because it's
it's it's related to the man in which i
talk about how
human consciousness is central to all of
this
and there's a manner in which although
we understand
these principalities as being above us
um
right these angels as being above us
there's a manner in which
if we were to participate
in christ to the extent that we can
then we would realize that
that we rule over the angels that the
i don't know house to say that to not
sound weird i don't know what to say but
it's like in terms of understanding that
things manifest themselves in human
consciousness
and that they are like a kind of a
result of
man capital m man
um
that it's actually i think it's a key to
kind of understanding
reality and i've argued with this with a
lot of people like you know i have good
friends they'll know who they'll know
who they are when i mention them who are
more like thomas and don't see the world
through the same vision as saint maximus
who has a sense in which
the human person is the laboratory where
all of this takes place the human person
is
the
it is ultimately the place in which the
seeds of all creation gets gathered
into
christ but christ as the incarnate man
and we are called to participate that
and there's even a manner in which that
incarnate man
you know maybe was like a good way to
understand it was that the incarnate man
is that was there at the outset was
there
right it is the incarnate christ that
created the world so so they say crazy
things to help you understand that which
is things like um
you know that when christ was on the
cross he was creating the world things
like that which sound completely crazy
but if you understand what is trying to
get to which is that you that the
creation
is linked or finds value in
consciousness
and human consciousness
uh then it doesn't it's not so weird
anymore that i said this in my
discussion
on uh like on jordan peterson's channel
the one video i did for the the jung
institute where i said
man is at the origin you know the world
is born in consciousness
and
to the extent that we have access to it
is born in human consciousness
yeah i don't know what makes sense
that's the place where heaven and earth
meet right that's that's the place where
evident earth meets so
so andrew says what is the symbol of the
anti-dora is it related to saint
christopher to the dogs eating the
crumbs that fall off the masters table i
think it it definitely is
it definitely is related to that but
also us like all to the extent that we
are also that like it's not just about
the outsiders but it is a sense in which
the the the the crumbs of the crumbs of
communion you know actually
fall into the world and you know the
blessings that come with liturgy you
know leak out into
into into reality and that you know the
the
the food of god reaches all the way to
the edge of the table and so i
definitely think that that's what the
anti-doran is related to
so nathan hart says what is the
symbolism of the ukraine versus russia
war being fought by two men named
vladimir volodymir and how does it
relate to universal history first for us
king to convert yeah
it's definitely
tragic is what it is i mean
you know the the
the ruse found their christianity in
kiev i mean that's where
that's where the origin of uh of russian
of the ruse uh says christianity is and
so prince vladimir was the prince of
kiev
so
yeah
it's a it's a definitely a horrible
situation all around like it's just it's
just
and it's um
and watching like just watching the
church devolve
you know
as this horrible war is going on is
you know people i've really decided that
i'm not gonna get
i'm not gonna speak about it too much
and uh there are reasons for that but i
hope people don't think it's because i
take that war lightly and that i that
i'm not seeing the tragedy that's
happening there
um
[Music]
so uh
there's something playing out folks like
there's some big story that is really
everything is winding up you know
and it's and in a manner it's like it's
a weird surprise but maybe not such a
weird surprise
that that the orthodoxy is thrust into
this like thrust into
the very place where all of this is is
kind of coagulating this whole big
wind-up
oh yeah
all right
all right so curious here and curious
are asked hello jonathan with the
symbolism
of
lisa says don't scare us
i'm sorry i feel like i've been i feel
like i feel like since especially since
copen started i feel like i've just it's
hard for me not to to say scary things
and i wish i didn't have to say the
things that i'm saying but i'm not going
to pretend like
i felt so bad man it's like i went i did
this q a at this college
and the q a
it was the subject was about the end of
the world their conference that i was
supposed to talk to two years ago and i
didn't like a year and a half ago or
whatever and so finally they said well
why don't you come and do that
conference we're going to do
so i did the conference which was about
how you know
how to help people understand the story
of enoch and how
you know what it means for fallen angels
to fall into the world and to bring
technology with them and to have corrupt
relations with women like you know that
for a lot of people it's like it's just
complete insanity
it's just a science fiction story so i'm
like i'm trying to help them understand
how
once intelligent patterns
get unleashed in the world then
there's a manner in which when the genie
is out of the bottle you can't control
it anymore it just runs right like you
you unleash a technology through desire
without understanding the ramifications
of all what it implies you just see the
increase in power you don't understand
what it's going to do in the world then
it does it
and you're like and then you're
surprised like you can't be surprised
these patterns are going to run and so i
was talking about that and talking about
nuclear you know nuclear war and talking
about
you know
basically being just talking about how
once the genie is out it's like
basically saying there's no su there's
no
big solution right now there's only
little solutions there's i can't there
is no big solution
and uh and it's like at the end man the
kids were just looking at me they're
like 18 years old they're just looking
at me
and the teacher bless his heart who i
appreciate him very much he's a nice man
just tried to recuperate the situation
he was like you know maybe you can give
us some positive something jonathan
maybe you could twist it into something
positive and i was like
yeah maybe anyway so anyways i talked
about i talked about you know building
an ark and talking and you know how we
need to reconnect in our communities
that's the only thing i could say
so uh yeah all right so cure
synchronously says hello jonathan what
is the symbolism of saint anthony the
centaur and the satter
i find it fascinating that he was
apparently born the same year saying
christopher was martyred thank you hope
you're well
interesting i didn't know that
um
so the idea of
the sort of saint anthony in the center
on the side it's super interesting
because it really is a nice little
cosmic image which is that
saint anthony goes out into the desert
and then he goes out into the wilderness
and then in the wilderness he encounters
monsters that's where you encounter
monsters right and those monsters are
images of his passions and our images of
his temptations so if you want to kind
of understand how later in western
iconography ultimately demons are
represented as a mixture of all these
different animals and stuff and and are
all kind of uh chimera and hybrids then
you can understand that
the story of saint anthony in the desert
is a recasting of these ancient hybrids
into
the moral
frame and the more connected frame of
of uh
of christian christian the christian
hierarchy of values because in a way the
centaurs and the satires even in roman
times and in greek times were already
images of human passions like look at
the stories of the centaur the story of
the the centaur's always trying to like
rape someone's women like that's all the
centaurs are always doing that and the
sadders are always also extremely
sexualized in roman iconography and uh
and in greek iconography and so the
relationship between
the the the hybrid animal
and a kind of disordered passion you
know it's like
what can i tell you saint anthony went
into the desert and fought and
encountered furries like i don't know
what else to say it's like that
nothing has changed it's still the same
now you know it's nothing has changed
all right
so arie fisher says hi jonathan mature
left a very interesting comment on
colonel for the catacombs recent video
saying that there was an important
tradition
that interprets 666 as being the
combination of the 600 years of noah
was alive in the height and the breadth
of the statue of nebuchadnezzar this is
come this comes from uh from saint
irenaeus of lyon i mentioned that in my
video on 666.
that just says that because the years of
noah's life have to do with time and the
measurement of the statue space
that 666 is more like an evil metaspace
than it is just space on steroids which
is how i understood it until now he also
relates this to our situation of the
coronavirus
a virus of crowns
what are your thoughts on this well dude
as usual that's here
if you can get insight from meteor like
there's no doubt about what it is like i
i've rarely heard him give any bad
insight and so
you know uh
the colonel of catacombs by the way go
watch it his
his videos are are wonderful and uh and
matsura's intuition is as usual
right on he always sees one level higher
and and i'll be honest with you often
one level higher than i can see
so would this be a way of distinguishing
between something like a system of
purity which just tries to cut off the
outside versus something more sinister
which tries to control both the inside
and the outside
yeah using one to accomplish the other
like ozymandias in the watchman exactly
that's a really good way of
understanding and so it's a manner in
which like i i've the way that i talked
about it is something like the idea of
accounting for everything like
accounting even for the exception and
like you said the idea of
you know you see that in the notion of
um
of of like even in the communist time or
and now right the idea of controlled
opposition the idea that you infiltrate
even your enemy and you actually have a
kind of system that incorporates even
your your enemy into it um yeah scary
stuff that's for sure
yep um
so scotty thorpe says hi jonathan
inspired by your recent video on the
anadromous can you elaborate on the
symbolism of puppets um i mean i don't
really know what else i
what else i could say that what i said
there i mean they're just extensions of
be of humans they are
they are often
uh kind of caricatures
different aspects of humanity you see
that especially in the more traditional
puppet shows where they represent
archetypes and so you can understand
them as as kind of extensions of uh
of of of what humans are
and even physically right because you
you kind of control them and they
manifest some element
so that's why i see that
all right ben case is i jonathan
tragically my cousin has been diagnosed
with terminal cancer at the age of 22.
i'm sorry to hear that
his doctors say most likely he has only
a matter of weeks to live to be honest
i'm completely unsure about
what to do about it or how to help
either story scripture or anything else
that you could recommend to navigate
such a troubling time
apologies for the heavy subject matter
and thank you for all your work
you know i mean
i would say
that
i would say that
the
the the death of someone you love
especially if it's something that is
announced and you know it's coming
is a is a tragedy
and it's something that you can't help
right you can't stop it i mean unless i
mean unless you're a saint maybe you
could you know but most of the time no
um
i would say that then take it as an
opportunity to love your cousin
and take it as an opportunity
to
show your cousin
compassion and affection in ways that
maybe you would not have done if he was
not in that situation that we live our
lives and we
we kind of have these superficial
relationships and we have these kind of
take things for granted and we take
people for granted you know just
normally and so i think that when
someone you love is
dying it's an opportunity to make those
last moments
shine as brightly as possible
so that's what i would encourage you to
do
all right kevin peterson asks
so
that does the principality of soccer
unite countries into itself if so does
it contribute to the breakdown
by creating its own subculture and so
well look there's there's a
there's a theory you know and that this
theory is a is a globalist theory
there's a theory
of the olympics
so i don't know if it's about if it's
about um
soccer i think that soccer is maybe too
low of an identity to really kind of
understand what's going on but there's a
sense in which in greek culture
casting uh the strife and casting the
competition
into a liturgical ritual practice
seemed to have been a way
to channel aggression and to channel
the different
conflicts into a kind of symbolic
a symbolic ritual that would embody it
but also maybe evacuate it so i think
that that's something
you could see in
i think that that's the function that
the olympics seemed to have had at the
time
at the in the greek greek states in the
greek cities and i think that there was
a desire to do that today i think
there's a desire for the olympics to
actually be that and so you can really
understand it like uh
you can understand it like you know how
animals will
uh
have a a show right they'll have a show
of strength and so you know how they'll
play fight and because they play fight
you know the male manifests his
supremacy and will have the females but
the word the person that you know
submits at the end of the play fight
doesn't have to die right doesn't have
to die
you know for the one
for the for the stronger male to to get
the
to get his boon let's say so i think
that that's one of the things that
sports can
is meant to do symbolically and
structurally in terms of civilization um
so i think that there's there's nothing
wrong with that you know um i mean
it seems to not be totally sufficient
but it it i mean it can play that role
to a certain extent i think and i think
in some manner it has
but um
but it's limited you know there's going
to be war anyways there are wars in the
greek states and there'll be there are
wars
since the olympics started so
all right so chandler turner asked i was
wondering about the symbolism of z
something
which we've all been seeing more of
recently
i mean it's not very complicated i don't
know is it really like especially in
terms of our languages it's just about
the end it's just the end so
that people have played that game with
like what is it that movie or that book
world war z where in a way it's like the
last war
but it's also the zombie war and so
there's a there's a relationship between
z like even the idea of people who talk
about generation z
understanding that it's like intuitively
talking about it as if it's the last
generation of something like it's it's a
weird it's a weird
because because you know people said
generation x and then it was generation
x was like generation without identity
but they didn't totally realize that
then it would be like kind of generation
y i guess and then generation z which is
like the last generation is that is that
what's going on here so uh so that's
usually what z
represents um
and so uh and then someone
mentioned the z like in terms of also
the azov battalion
that there's something going on there
which has to do with the end as well but
i don't know if that's what it is but at
least that's the way that
that um
that's the way that it plays out at
least for us when we think of z we think
about the
end um
so nicola alexis lexic asks when jacob
was leaving his uncle laban what was the
significance of rachel stealing laban's
hustle idols and then successfully
hiding them during the search
if you want to understand that
there's some humor in that story if you
want to understand that you have to
understand how she hides them
she hides them by saying that she has
her period and that she can't get up
from the
you know
from where she's sitting because she has
her period and so if you want to
understand
what it means for for rachel
to steal
the foreign gods and the remainders to
take with her the remainders of her
brother's house
back into
um
back to israel
you could say that that's the story of
israel like it's the story of israel all
the time right it's the story of israel
leaving leaving egypt bringing with it
the gods of egypt the the golden calf
bringing with it also
the mixed multitudes that are in egypt
with them
and then
[Music]
they make it becoming very difficult for
things to integrate
because of this problem
but also it's like it's part of the
story it's like it's it's part of the
story you know the
it's part of the cycle like if you want
to get the whole cycle it also includes
that that part at the end there's these
remainders and those remainders
are part of the or the story and so i
think that that's what's being
represented here
like if you want to understand if you
want to understand menstruation it's
like that story will help you understand
menstruation sorry sorry guys
you guys asked the question
all right luca
irremads symbolically are software
developers like blacksmith
who would be the closest to or are we
our own breed
i mean software developers are like
blacksmiths in sense that blacksmiths
are the ultimate representatives of of
technical people in the ancient world
right you have the image of the
blackfist of tubal kane as a blacksmith
or of
hephaestus as the blacksmith god is is
the ultimate image of what technology is
so you're right they are in a way the
modern uh
the modern blacksmith so
yeah
all right so brandon
says what is the symbolism of the
medieval sword specifically of its
representation as an upside down cross
um
so i don't think it's seen as an upside
down cross
uh
it does definitely there's a
relationship between the sword and the
cross
but i don't think that it's understood
as an upside down cross when people use
it
um
i've never seen anything that refers to
that there is a sense in which you know
you see the knight who turns his cross
around and then almost
has it in front of him almost like a
cross that he's venerating the cross so
definitely that's something that i've
seen that type of imagery but i don't
think it's ever understood as an
upside-down cross but i mean the
symbolism of the medieval sword is just
the symbolism of authority and symbolism
of of of the power of the of the king or
the noble man of the night you know
all right alex couches what is symbolism
meaning behind john the baptist
beheading
i'd live by the sword die by the sword
that's what christ said right and so
the the
you can understand
the
you can understand beheading as the
separation of body and of soul and body
that's what beheading is it's a
separation of heaven and earth
um
all right i'm kind of winding down here
guys it's been two hours okay normal
goldeneye says hi jonathan is there a
relationship between the ark and the
circus caravan it seems like the circus
is revealed as a total facade and the
reality of how it travels from place to
place while the ark is revealed as the
light of the new world are both remnants
one of the old world and
other of a new one beginning thoughts
this is this is not your question but
i'm going to answer it in a way that
that will maybe surprise you there's
definitely a relationship
between
the ark of the covenant
when it is taken by the foreign
nation and the circus caravan
because all the symbolism of it you know
like causing uh
causing deformations in the groin area
and causing growth in the growing area
and then also uh you know being related
to rats and mice and
infestations of of vermin and then the
idea of uh
you know having to make these little
like idols of of uh tumors and and of uh
and of rats
and then
letting the ark like
the ark just go on its own like led by
animals
you know for it to finally return to
jerusalem where there it ceases to have
its kind of
it ceases to have the effect of what
happens when the center is taken out
like when the center is taken out of its
proper place um so i think for sure
there's a relationship between those two
um
i don't know about the arc of noah
though
that's something to think about
all right guys and so sorry a few dark
questions in this and a few like a few
questions
a little slightly inappropriate answers
i mean it's hard because sometimes
assuming these things you if if that's
what we're talking it's like that's the
question that's the that's the answer so
sorry hopefully
hopefully everybody's doing okay so uh
so everybody thanks for your thanks for
your attention thanks for showing up
and uh there's a lot of stuff going on i
will let you know there's some
interesting announcements i'll probably
be making soon the website is being
worked on again finally i think i
mentioned that last month you know the
designer is is everything is
supposedly coming together and we'll
have what we hoped for last year and
never happened god's dog is finally out
that is the pdf the the printing is
still going on and that's not totally
finished but at least i decided to uh to
release the pdf out to everybody that
backed it those that haven't um that
didn't back it on indiegogo there is
also a link
to if you go to godsdog.com it will
bring you to a pre-sale store that we're
is still going to be open for a little
while until we kind of lock all the
printing until the printing's finished
i'm going to leave the open
the pre-sale store open until we run out
of books like if we sell all the books
then then that will close so um so if
you're interested there's a way to back
it and uh thanks everybody for your
attention thanks to lisa i know it's
late for you thanks to brad also for
for for moderating
um i always appreciate you guys and and
i'll talk to everybody very soon bye